hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the DNA's test which is just one
of many biochemical tests that one can
carry out in a laboratory to distinguish
differentiate between different types of
bacteria so the DNA's test which is also
sometimes called the DNA hydrolysis test
is a test to detect a particular
bacterial enzyme so some bacteria
secrete an EXO enzyme known as DNA's and
this breaks DNA down into nucleotides
and you might be saying to yourself why
do bacteria want to break down their DNA
well it's not their DNA that they want
to break down because sometimes there
will be DNA floating around outside the
cell usually from another recently
killed bacterial cell
so if a bacterial cell dies all of its
DNA spills out into the environment and
other bacteria that are around may want
to break that DNA down to use the
nucleotides those building blocks that
make up DNA to replicate their own DNA
now DNA is typically too large to cross
the membrane by itself but there are
transporters like transporter proteins
for individual nucleotides so some
bacteria can produce this EXO enzyme
DNA's secrete it outside of themselves
where it can break down DNA that's
outside in the environment and then that
bacteria can use their transporter
proteins to bring in the resulting
nucleotides and then use them to
replicate their own DNA so some species
of bacteria that can do this are
Staphylococcus aureus Serratia
marcescens and some strains of
Campylobacter jejuni
all of these are known to cause disease
in humans and so are clinically relevant
now there are two methods to carry out
the DNA's test one with methyl green and
one
hi with hydrochloric acid but before we
talk about the two individual methods
let's just talk about how the results
are analyzed because it's pretty similar
so when we're interpreting results the
bacterial isolates are Street onto a
plate and if there is a clear zone
around the bacterial streak as there is
in this case but not in this case
this clear zone indicates the presence
of DNA's it indicates that this isolate
could produce DNA sand secrete it and
break down DNA that was in the medium
and let's talk about the two different
methods the first one we'll talk about
is the moment methyl green so there's a
test auger which contains DNA or the
d-nice to break down if there's DNA's
present in that isolate as well as
something called methyl green so you
inoculate the test auger just by making
a streak of the isolate and incubate at
35 degrees Celsius for 24 to 48 hours
and then you observe and the way that
you interpret it is you know that
methylene complexes with DNA but not
with free nucleotides
so wherever there's DNA present that
methyl green will complex with it making
the auger green but wherever the DNA has
been broken down into free nucleotides
because of this EXO enzyme DNA's there
will be a clear zone and so that would
indicate a DNA spa's ative result the
other method with hydrochloric acid is
to inoculate test auger again which
contains DNA that if DNA is present it
can break down incubate at 35 degrees
Celsius for 24 to 48 hours and then to
flood the plate with one in hydrochloric
acid now this in stands for normality if
you've had chemistry then you've
probably heard of normality it's a
different way of describing a
concentration it's related to molarity
but it's not the same thing but anyway
flood the plate with one in hydrochloric
acid and then wait a few minutes and
observe free nucleotides are soluble in
this one in HCL solvent woth whole non
broken-down DNA precipitates
so again we are looking for a clear zone
because free nucleotides are soluble
there will be a clear zone around the
bacterial isolate while DNA will
precipitate so any wherever there is
still DNA present there will be sort of
cloudiness not a clear zone so that is
it for the DNA test if you're
understanding other biochemical tests I
have a playlist where I have videos
describing things like the catalase test
and the coagulase test in the oxidase
test and many other biochemical tests
like that so if you're interested in
those please check them out and thank
you for watching biology professor